le président du sénat gérard larcher
l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
ce rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse
trois grandes parties comme chaque
semaine et trois grandes questions pour
vous premièrement est-ce que ça va mieux
comme le prétend françois hollande
avec ce chiffre que l'on a appris tout à
l'heure 60 mille chômeurs de moins au
mois de mars dans la foulée de cette
annonce spectaculaire ce méga-contrat de
34 milliards de d'euros de sous-marins à
passer par l'australie deuxième grande
question est ce qu'on assiste à l'envol
de françois fillon votre champion qui
avait un peu disparu des écrans radar
c'est votre candidat donc pour la
primaire encore loin certes d'alain
juppé nicolas sarkozy mais son
changement de ton il promet désormais de
casser la baraque semble porter
questions sur la primaire tout à l'heure
avec guillaume daudin de la fp enfin
troisième partie des missions troisième
question est ce que le sénat fait
obstacle à la nouvelle réunion du
congrès qui avait été prévu cette fois
pour réformer le conseil supérieur de la
magistrature alors est ce qu'il ya un
changement de pied des sénateurs sur ce
sujet sur ce texte qui a été approuvé
tout à l'heure par les députés que les
sénateurs avaient approuvé même vous
répondrai tout à l'heure notamment au
ministre de la justice et avec tous ces
sujets en lien avec le sénat vous
répondrez à michael à metz de public
sénat
mais d'abord donc jarrar chez est ce que
pour vous ça va mieux comme le prétend
françois hollande qui attend comme tous
les français bien sûr l'inversion de la
courbe et là hop -1 7% au mois de mars
d'abord aujourd'hui de bonnes nouvelles
à contrat de commandes de sous marins
comme toujours il faut qu'ils soient
confirmés puisque on est face à une
alternance possible en australie mais
moi je m'en réjouis
c'est le signe de l'excellence française
c'est le signe aussi d'une la qualité de
notre armée parce qu'il ya aussi l'image
de notre armée et puis chiffres du
chômage qui à la différence du mot
dernier est meilleur je rappelle que le
chiffre du chômage faut les juger sur la
durée mais au fond quand j'ai entendu
françois hollande d'une sentiment qu'on
regardait pas le même pays
en fait notre pays il se sent pas bien
et on le voit dans la rue on le voit
dans les coeurs on le voit dans les
sondages
dans ce que nous entendons et peut-être
avec ces chiffres et ces indicateurs
économiques très jeunes joueuses de
l'ong souhaite pour mon pays parce que
ça conduit mon pays à aller vers autre
chose que les forces politiques qui font
partie des valeurs démocratiques mais
que je constate c'est que nous avons sur
moins de quatre ans plus huit cent mille
chômeurs de catégorie a c'est un chiffre
incontournable nous avons une dette
une dette qui ne cesse de croître même
si les taux d'intérêt sont à zéro je
dois le dire
nous avons en plus une situation
politique où il ya plus de confiance
entre l'exécutif et du pays entre le
chef de l'état et le pays on a une
majorité fragmentée éclatée où en fait a
vraiment un vrai projet politique est
remplacé par la une d'un grand magazine
on voit un ministre sa fiche est alors
que le pays souffre vous partirez annuel
maxent et pour le soir qui le soir mais
sans doute c'était pour dire que son
ennemi c'était la finance était à laon
le soir où le président de la république
tente de s'expliquer devant thalassa pas
des inventions s'arrête parce que vous
venez très ténu mais réel à gérard
larcher vous nous dites n'y a pas de
futur on a pas d'espoir avec le pouvoir
actuel non à tout à fait à la gauche
dans toute démocratie suffit pas de
s'agiter y compris à la faculté de
médecine pour avoir aidé finir un avenir
je crois que il y à un sujet majeur
c'est la confiance entre le pays
pourquoi parce que le président il s'est
engagé
il s'est engagé il ya quatre ans
notamment sur la courbe du chômage c'est
pas un mois
je souhaite vraiment que le chômage soit
parce que pour moi c'est une balle
absolue dans mon pays mais en même temps
on a une europe en crise est-ce qu'on
compte dans les négociations de genève
sur la syrie voilà des vrais sujets je
lire la réussite du président c'est sans
doute l'intervention en afrique
si je devais en reconnaître une quand
même pas reconnaître une commun je
voudrais que mon pays à mieux oui mais
alors donc et vous allez continuer à
rappeler qu'au delà des variations
saisonnières du chômage seront on espère
que ça va continuer à s'améliorer
je vais continuer à rappeler que le
chômage aph ex
depuis le début du quinquennat c'est
donc ça que vous allez tenir sur dix sur
30 de chômage tout le monde le sait et
là je note que d'après les premières
analyses ce serait les entrées en stage
mais méfions-nous les chiffres mensuels
françois hollande maintient en tous les
cas son credo et il était évidemment
très heureux tout à l'heure de rendre
visite à la dcns pour célébrer ces
raisons je serai bien commun alors oui
on les côtes
la france va mieux ça ne va pas mieux
pour tout le monde
à l'évidence une a beaucoup dans notre
pays qui souffre qui suppose des
questions même par rapport à leur avenir
j'imagine que au moment même où on
annonce un succès de cette importance
d'autres peuvent être dans l'inquiétude
sur leur propre emploi ou sur leur
propre industrie et faut avoir confiance
en nous mêmes j'ai évoqué votre propre
situation est à peine deux ans trois ans
des doutes qui pouvaient exister et dans
beaucoup d'entreprises
et puis il ya cette capacité qui est la
nôtre d'aller de l'avant d'avoir
confiance en nous de porter de l'est ce
point alors ce contrat pour les sous
marins australiens donc c'est un motif
de fierté pour la france pour vous aussi
vous l'avez déjà alors chez meys voilà
al'inverse par exemple de manuel valls à
ne vous rend pas optimistes pour le pays
je jalili et c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle corps et âme on va pas ne pas
la goûter comme et les puisqu'on sait
que ça aura un effet si elle et
concrétiser cette bonne nouvelle de plus
de 4000 emplois je pense à cherbourg je
pense à lorient je pense que non je
pense aux sous-traitants un extrêmement
nombreux je pense aussi à la nécessité
pour notre pays de dégager pour son
armée 2% du pib chaque année pour que
nous soyons à la hauteur mais en même
temps la question qui est posée c'est
est ce que ce pays
il a besoin de réformes il a besoin de
changer et on voit bien que c'est pas la
loi sur le travail qui va conduire à ce
changement à ce propos justement est ce
que quand il viendra ce texte devant le
sénat vous allez le rétablir dans sa
version initiale donc dans un sens plus
favorable aux anges
il appartiendra à la commission ou
commissions concernées sans aucun doute
de remettre un certain nombre de
marqueurs mais nous l'avions déjà fait
au moment de la loi macron
coup beaucoup des propositions qui ont
été dans la première version de la loi
travail était déjà des propositions que
le sénat avait porté sur le texte macro
alors on a parlé de du rassemblement et
au la gauche
hier soir à paris vous avez parlé de la
faculté de médecine prochain meeting
prévu à lille avec l'objectif est
également de mettre en avant le clivage
droite gauche on écoute la ministre de
la santé qui était sur l'antenne de
public sénat ce matin pour défendre
cette initiative donc réveillé la gauche
sur le thème de la fierté aussi des
réalisations depuis le début du
quinquennat
la france elle va mieux que ne le
pensent les français
il y a dans notre pays des sources de
dynamisme d'innovation de transformation
de modernité et c'était ça la réunion
d'hier c'était non pas de prétendre que
tout va très bien dans le meilleur des
mondes possibles mais que une
mobilisation pour montrer ce qui a été
fait est nécessaire et notamment dire à
ceux qui nous font un procès androni
mans vous vous trompez
ça n'est pas vrai et regarder ce qui a
été fait alors les ministres présents
hier soir ont voulu réactiver le clivage
droite gauche donc en contradiction avec
emmanuel macron que vous avez cités est
ce que pour vous il ya un phénomène
macron dans ce pays gérard larcher je
crois qui a tous les cas une bulle mais
comme les bulles de savon un moment il
faisait cap parce que monsieur macron il
doit d'abord faire aller mieux
l'économie française
c'est sa première tâche et il est quoi
qu'il en dise l'obligé du président de
la république il n'a pas tiré d'une
élection sa légitimité mais de sa
compétence aux côtés du président de la
république
quand j'entends la ministre je pense que
la médecine de molière vous savez je
vais mieux je vais mieux mais finalement
est-ce que je vais aller mieux
ça fait penser aussi aux cas briller au
général de gaulle quand on parlait
d'europe
est-ce qu'on est là qu'on peut rester au
gouvernement selon vous aujourd'hui
écoutez il appartient au président de la
république de prendre de décision mais
je dois vous dire que je suis quand même
étonné à moi qu'il y ait une forme de
publicité que je n'ose imaginer un
gouvernement salou est une équipe et
dans cette équipe
un modèle instruments des chefs de
l'état mais je pense qu'il a d'abord
besoin d'être autour du premier ministre
c'est comme ça que je conçois une équipe
gouvernementale
vous avez évoqué le climat de
contestation générale dans le dans le
pays ne retombe pas puisqu'il y aura une
nouvelle journée de mobilisation jeudi
contre la loi travail alors que la cgt
je sais bien ce que vous suivait de très
près toutes les questions syndicales
gérard larcher en tant qu'ancien
ministre du travail notamment la cgt a
montré le visage de la radicalisation
lors de son congrès restant à marseille
en écoute philippe martinez nous notre
référence parce que sinon on va pas s'en
sortir c'est pas le moins disant social
parce que bientôt on va nous comparer à
qui le modèle social indien ou du
bangladesh
c'est ça la référence donc à baisser les
droits des salariés en france s'est
donné un mauvais signe est ce que ça
vous inquiète cette radicalisation de la
cgt doivent d'abord le mieux disant
social c'est celui qui a des taux de
chômage comparable allemagne ou à
l'autriche
voilà et des vrais comparaison est ce qu
ont satisfait de la situation
d'aujourd'hui d'avoir 25% des jeunes
hors de l'emploi
est ce que c'est ça être le mieux disant
social je dois dire qu'il faut qu'on
change de registre
sur ce sujet quand chances de logiciels
y compris moi même par rapport à des
conceptions que je pouvais avoir
il ya 12 ans aujourd'hui mais il faut
faire confiance dans l'entreprise
vous avez évolué vos magouilles évolué
et je considère que c'est d'abord dans
un rapport de confiance avec les
entreprises que seules entreprises
créent la richesse et donc l'emploi
en même temps il faut des stabilisateurs
sociaux le temps est venu j'avais fait
un rapport en 2007 sur ce sujet qui
marquait mon évolution
d'ailleurs je l'avais fait avec la
commission européenne sur la nécessaire
flexibilité la nécessité du dialogue
dans l'entreprise et en même temps de la
sécurisation des parcours professionnels
des salariés
alors vous avez vous plaidez il ya un
instant pour des grandes réformes qui
sont nécessaires dans le pays est ce
qu'elles seront possibles en 2017 si
l'alternance dans un pays si éruptif oui
si on lui dise qu'on veut faire et si on
fait ce qu'on a dit c'est l'averse de ce
qu'on vit depuis quatre ans il tout
autre chose dans l'actualité et c'est la
question identitaire qui peut être sera
au coeur de la campagne de 2010 est en
tous les cas manuel valls en parle
beaucoup et il met en garde contre
certaines dérives
je crois que vous le rejoignez sur ce
point gérard larcher écouter céline pina
qui est une ancienne conseillère
régionale ps du val-d'oise qui pointe la
menace islamiste dans beaucoup de
quartiers
une menace qui est dirigée contre des
populations abandonnées dit elle cet
abandon des populations favorise le rôle
prescripteur pour le coup aux temps des
salafistes que des frères musulmans se
sont pas des terroristes dire qui est le
passage à l'acte sanglant n'est pas
forcément inscrits dans leur stratégie
en revanche il prépare le basculement de
ceux qui choisissent de passer à l'acte
parce que leur vision du monde et leur
vision de la société est exactement la
même et parmi les premières choses
auxquelles ils vont s'attaquer ça va
être l'égalité femme homme est un des
instruments les plus forts pour le faire
c'est le voile ce qui aujourd'hui est
dangereux c'est qu'on abandonne des
populations entières dans certains
quartiers et ne sont plus travaillés que
par ses messages politiques là ça
devient la norme
voilà propos recueillis par jardine
bavois l'eau et vous vous même vous avez
des craintes écouter sur les exécutifs
locaux qui pourrait basculer gérard
larcher il ya un an
j'écrivais au président de la république
souvenez-vous la nation un héritage en
partage après les événements dramatiques
de janvier il avait sollicité claude
bartolone il m'avait sollicité pour une
réflexion et je lui disais que le pire
des dangers étaient le repli
communautaire dans ce pays je voyais il
y avait d'autres facteurs mais celui là
et je crois que un des sujets c'est
d'abord en dehors d'identité c'est
qu'est ce que nous voulons faire de la
république est ce qu'il ya une
communauté nationale et dans cette
communauté nationale
l'affirmation qu'il n'y a pas d'autres
constitutions que la constitution de la
république quand on voit un certain
nombre de textes issus des frères
musulmans ont dit la charia notre
constitution bien non je pense qu'il ya
un islam tout à fait compatible avec les
valeurs de la république j'aurais pas
parler de celui qui vous ayez un peu
moi je parle aussi de celui qui avec
lequel la république est compatible et
puis assurée et ben qui sont pas dans
les valeurs de la république et la 6è
république tout simplement de s'exprimer
la république l'a fait il ya 110 ans en
1905 mais ce qu'elle a fait preuve de
lâcheté certains élus locaux nous
expliquer comment ces dernières années
nous sommes tous nous avons tous parfois
démissionner nous avons tous parfois
démissionner devant certaines atteintes
notamment l'égalité hommes-femmes et
vous craignez effectivement que des
islamistes prennent le pouvoir local
elle s'ils sont élus par la boîte de la
démocratie dans un certain nombre de
territoires
eh bien il faudra que la république
réaffirme que on ne transige pas avec
les valeurs de la république
ça c'est un message qui dépasse les
clivages gauche droite jean marie le
guen a dit il ya quelques jours le
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement comme que vous connaissez bien
a dit qu'aujourd'hui dans notre pays la
république n'allait plus de soi pour
tout le monde c'est un constat que vous
dressez également gérard larcher elle
peut ne pas aller de soi pour quelques
uns
et bien moi je vous réaffirme que la
république a le devoir de défendre les
valeurs républicaines et d'être
intransigeantes cette république sur ses
valeurs parmi lesquelles la cité des
principes d'égalité hommes-femmes les
principes de liberté
les principes d'état de droit qui
doivent l'emporter et il n'y a pas de
lois religieuses quelles qu'elles soient
j'ai mes propres convictions qu'ils
soient supérieurs en lois de la
république
on est bien sûr là au delà du clivage
droite gauche et on est au delà de la
seule question de l'islam est-ce que
vous avez été choqué par la journée du
voile à sciences po la semaine des
rejets me méfie de toutes les
provocations et les prosélytisme
c'est vrai parfois dans le cadre de
certains voiles qui sont portés et qui
sont mes retrouver mon rapport tous âges
a écrit un an et je le dis clairement
attention à jouer avec un certain nombre
de concepts la république
elle traverse aujourd'hui une période
difficile et notre devoir est de ne pas
jouer avec les boîtes d'allumettes
je crois que c'est important je crois à
une seule communauté nationale et cette
communauté nationale elle doit être
capable d'assimiler c'est le mot du code
civil n'en ayant pas peur
manuel valls et évoque beaucoup cette
question il d'autres identitaire
d'ailleurs une
ne redoute pas le mot 1 vous le soutenez
alors qu'il est lui critiqué sur ce
point là vous le savez pas par une
partie de la gauche tranquille nous
rappelle les valeurs de la république
etc sont des valeurs qui départ seul à
seul clivage gauche droite je le dis
nous avons ensemble à bien commun et qui
s'appelle la république c'est peut-être
une répétition ce que je fais mais ont
une communauté nationale et se sont
rappelés communautaire c'est le plus
grand des dangers qui nous traversent ce
sera un des enjeux de 2017 ce sera un
des enjeux de 2017 et des années qui
suivent
car il faudra du courage pour conduire
qu ont résisté notamment un fait
par exemple il ya plus d'enfants
français de confession israélite dans un
certain nombre d'écoles publiques est-ce
que vous croyez que c'est acceptable est
parti à man où la reprise n saint denis
c'est ce que dénonce seine-saint-denis a
eu d'autres endroits
quand je vois des compatriotes de
confession israélite
vous parlez de partir je trouve ça pour
ma part inadmissible dans une république
qui doit protéger chacun des siens
quelle que soit son origine sa race son
histoire et ses convictions
deuxième partie de preuves par 3 avec
guillaume daudin donc de l'agencé france
presse qui va nous rejoindre pour
évoquer les primaires de novembre et la
remontée de votre champion en françois
fillon un bond de 2,5 points il a doublé
son score à 15 %
l'analyse d'abord des douars de jérôme
sainte-marie sondeurs et politologues
françois fillon des forces spécifiques
on sait que son livre par exemple
a très bien marché en librairie
peut-être que aussi où les sympathisants
de droite qui savent qu'ils ont encore
du temps avant de se décider
et bien leur intérêt fluctue selon les
moments il ya eu un moment sarkozy mais
un moment juppé d'être vivant il ya un
moment le maire surtout les très
récemment
peut-être couleurs et ils veulent
s'intéresser un petit peu à françois
fillon je pense qu'il ya un petit jeu
s'ils voulaient du sympathisants de
droite avec les sondages actuellement
voilà guide un bon soir au fort en
question gérard larcher soutient donc de
françois fillon
et voilà et justement ces derniers temps
françois fillon a décidé de cogner un
peu plus contre ses rivaux dans divers
sondages il a regagné quelques points il
est repassé devant bruno le maire alors
on lui aurait dit ça je croyais à il ya
cinq ans alors à étonner mais qu' il dit
qu'il soit derrière maintenant il est
devant à nouveau
vous pensez qu'il ya quelque chose qui
repartent pour lui je pense que d'abord
la primaire elle est en train de se
mettre en place dans la tête de nos
concitoyens et que chacune et chacun de
nos concitoyens en âge de voter qui se
retrouvent dans les valeurs du centre et
de la droite républicaine va avoir envie
de s'exprimer
on en était la preuve par 3 en fin
d'année dernière n'aura dit est ce qu'il
y aura une primaire je vous réponds oui
on a les bureaux de vote
on a des listes électorales depuis
vendredi on a un guide électorale et la
commission d'organisation près des
primaires dont je suis mort
peut-être avec un statut de sage à
l'intérieur casques bleus certes non non
non ça c'est une invention de fin de
semaine surveillez les dérapages quand
même un don avec un sarkozyste un juppé
il ya une autorité de la chose qui
compte c'est que les primaires vont
avoir lieu qui aura un débat laurent du
projet que ça commencera ce débat au
mois de septembre de manière formelle
d'accord avec des débats dans les médias
et que d'ici là il est naturel que
chacun des candidats fassent valoir ou
vend lui s'il est déclaré dans cette
candidature
son projet ses idées c'est ce que fait
françois fillon c'est ce que fait alain
juppé
c'est ce que fait bruno le maire comment
expliquez vous donc que justement ces
derniers temps il arrive un peu plus à
sortir de la nasse dans laquelle il
était un peu en ferrer je sais pas mais
nous aurons vent a d'abord pas du tout
mais on voit qu'il ya de nombreux
parlementaires et le soutiennent voilà
c'est assez révélateur
alors qu'il n'était pas au mieux de sa
forme sur le baromètre mais les sondages
il s'est trouvé beaucoup de parlements
forme d'assises et une assise parce
qu'il a aussi un projet solide mais il y
aura un certain nombre de parlementaires
qui soutiendront alain juppé et d'autre
mais je crois que la primaire je veux
qu'elle réussisse je veux que à l'issue
d'un débat y ait un projet que le 27 au
soir ce sera une de mes responsabilités
soyons tous rassemblés derrière celui ou
celle qui sera acheminé est ce que je
pensais que françois fillon que coiffer
tout le monde sur le poteau
je ne sais pas parce que moi vous savez
je suis un homme de chevaux de course
d'orient et je ne vous dit jamais qui va
gagner le prix de l'arc de triomphe mais
en début de saison alors je crois que
c'est soixante douze parlementaires qui
ont annoncé leur soutien à monsieur
fillon justement dans une liste qui l'a
dévoilé récemment et il manquait
quelques soutiens très connue est le
vôtre notamment b il ne manquera pas au
soutien
c'est même le seul tir en province mais
le statut particulier c'est d'ailleurs
le cas de bernard accoyer aussi que nous
avons à l'intérieur de la commission
nous sommes là pour être des hommes
aussi de rassemblement d'accord les
hommes d' équilibre ce qui n'empêche pas
que moi je chemine avec françois fillon
je ne cesse de le répéter et bien
longtemps avec philippe seguin alors en
tous les cas on l'a entendu l'ancien
premier ministre prône une réelle
rupture radicale et bien du coup pour
jean marie le guen cela représente pour
la france un danger on écoute la
ministre et evo réagissait dans la
radicalité quand j'entends monsieur
fillon parlait de dire qu'il veut casser
la baraque
la baraque en question c'est notre
modèle social il y a des gens qui vont
prendre comme méthode politique
la rupture violente en 2017 qui pour
mettre à bas notre modèle social pour
mettre à bas des règles républicaines
alors que l'action
moi je vais vous reparler de l'état de
la baraque faisons l'inventaire plus de
10% de chômeurs 25% de jeunes au chômage
c'est ça l'état de la baraque même si
elle va si bien la baraque
c'est vrai qu'il faut pas la casser que
dit monsieur le guen a trait à 2600
milliards de dette au 30 juin prochain
alors c'est sûr gardons la baraque
ce qu'on propose c'est vraiment un
changement d'accord le disais tout à
l'heure et en répondant aux questions de
votre confrère je disais tout à l'heure
il faut vraiment changer de logiciel
d'accord il faut retrouver le chemin
vers le plein emploi vers la croissance
nous avons une croissance en berne dans
notre pays et il ne suffira pas même si
je m'en réjouis commandes de sous marins
ou de rafale et il faut retrouver ce
chemin de la croissance et la baraque au
fond elle est en train de s'effondrer
sur la france il faut plutôt construire
une nouvelle maison dans l'est dans les
divers quand il ya toujours des échanges
d'amabilités chez alain juppé on
commence à entendre qu'en fait le
programme de françois fillon c'est celui
d'un outsider c'est à dire qu'il est
tellement radical qu'en fait ils
seraient irréalisables et qu' il ya des
mesures qui sont proposés par exemple il
veut supprimer
vous vous dites si je m'égare 600 mille
fonctionnaires en cinq ans c'est à dire
ne pas embaucher un seul fonctionnaire
en cinq ans et on nous dit à nous
journalistes qu'en fait c'est pas un
programme réaliste c'est pas un
programme de quelqu'un qui veut
gouverner tous les cas si on mai 2010
triste un projet construit depuis bien
longtemps
et avant même que les sondages ne le
mesure c'est un projet fut peu encore
est à débattre
moi par exemple je suis sur certains
aspects un peu moins libérale que
françois fillon tout le monde le sait
tout le monde sait que je contribue à
apporter un certain nombre d'éléments d'
équilibre avec d'autres je pense aux
politiques d'aménagement du territoire
je pense à la dimension de la ruralité
je pense à ce que la france ne se résume
pas à quelques métropoles quelques
régions puissante et je sais que ces
idées aujourd'hui françois fillon les
reprend alors mettaient en garde contre
un certain de coupes budgétaires
non
le met pas en garde contre le retour à
l'équilibré budgétaire mais c'est la
méthode de retour à l'équilibré
budgétaire qui doit se faire d'une
manière progressive mais volontaire
parce que aujourd'hui quand même dire
les choses
les promesses du président de la
république c'est quoi 4 milliard de
dépenses en plus c'est pas moi qui le
dis un grand journal économique hier
vont s'ajouter 3 milliards pour edf
7 milliards comment les finances dans
une situation de déficit et de déficit
j'allais dire par rapport aux
engagements européens c'est ça les
réalités et donc pas voir des candidats
qui s'engagent dans la vérité avec le
courage c'est ce qu'attendent les
français
les français ils veulent plus entendre
moi président il veut l'entendre que
doit devenir la france avec le projet
que je propose c'est ce que dit monsieur
fillon c'est tout un tas de coupes
sèches net et massif repose et vous
paraît et je réalise que les évolutions
budgétaires qui sont significatives mais
comment voulez vous redresser le pays
qu'est ce qu'a fait schoder en allemagne
alors à guillaume daudin nous a rapporté
des propos entendus donc dans les
milieux gps voilà voilà bien ce qu'est
ce que quand même vous êtes inquiet de
la tournure que pourrait prendre vu les
mêmes ou pas du nez ou pas du tout parce
que c'est logique
alain juppé avec sa personnalité ses
qualités et c'est un homme d'état il
peut avoir une approche différente de
celle de françois fillon sur la méthode
mais l'objectif est le même redresser la
france il fait retrouver la croissance
redonner confiance demain dans une
france mais sa femme de dean vulgaire
d'exporter de reconstruire une europe
parce qu'aujourd'hui on est face à une
europe qui s'interroge crise des
migrants briques site interrogations
d'allemagne sur la politique de la
banque centrale européenne eh bien je
dois dire que c'est au contraire de ces
idées là que nous allons faire une vraie
proposition
voilà pourquoi le 27 celui qui sera
choisi sera le porter à la fois de son
projet mais de la richesse du projet
dont ils auront débattu tous ensemble et
dans l'assemblée primaire il est écrit
que chacun des candidats s'engagent à
soutenir mais aussi à participer à la
campagne du futur gagnant vous pensez
qu'on aura
après la primaire une belle photo de
famille avec noé anciens candidats non
le maillot de famille que j'entends
c'est un pack 1 gagner pour la france
d'accord mais pour gagner en mai et pour
jouer l'alternance
alors moi je suis dans une vie très
antérieur et jouer au rugby
je veux bien est un des piliers du pack
il ya certains des candidats à cette
primaire geoffroy didier ou nathalie
kosciusko morizet qui disent qu'en fait
elle et elle est un peu verrouiller
cette primaire nathalie kosciuko morizet
dise est en fait c'est sarkozy juppé
fillon le maire qui veulent faire la
primaire entre eux et il n'ya pas
d'accéder dans une autre à cause des
parrainages et parce qu'on ait adopté
des statuts
parce que la primaire est une chose
sérieuse et qu'il est logique qu'on
entend dans la primaire un peu comme
dans le processus des présidentielles et
donc on a adopté depuis je crois même
que certains d'entre vous votez ses
statuts au bureau politique eh bien on
les respecte
on fonctionne avec des règles on
fonctionne pas avec des humeurs leur
candidature à la candidature est
légitime mais elle est illégitime
mais le moment nuira les candidats et
bien les combien selon vous faudrait
être cinq ou six je pense mais oui mais
c'est savez je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure pour le prix de l'arc de
triomphe et méfions nous des pronostics
à l'avance et là je pense que il ya eu
même fait à être autour de six candidats
le fait qu' un nombre illimité de parler
sur les républicains
bien sûr mais le fait qu' un nombre
illimité de parlementaires puissent
soutenir un candidat au final ça bloque
la candidature par un nombre illimité
ça voudrait dire que la droite et le
centre et il y à jour y donne l
argumentaire ça va un peu échappé jusque
là illimitée dans l'allier emblée le
nombre de parts de nommer c'est très
simple vous avez à peu près de 100
députés républicains
une trentaine de centristes vous en avez
ici 144 est républicain vous avez 44
centriste quelques noms inscrits voilà
le vivier dans lequel aujourd'hui
peuvent cacher les candidats ne pas
piocher retrouver leur confiance de ses
lectures utile ou puéril justement de
montrer ses muscles à travers un nombre
record de
de parrainage comme françois fillon l'a
fait d'ailleurs en annonçant ses 72 non
et en attendant le vote en cet homme
c'est autre chose
françois fillon est il démontrait à
l'issue d'un processus de construction
d'un projet que est un moment qui
n'était pas évident pour lui
au lancement de sa campagne qui avait
lieu à paris auxquelles j'ai participé
et bien qu'il avait un nombre de
parlementaires qui se retrouvaient
autour de son projet il n'était pas là
uniquement comme des fans qui ont
participé à la construction de son
projet et qui ont envie de le faire
partager au pays alors dans le mondial
dans la plupart des sondages des
enquêtes d'opinion actuelle c'est
clairement marine le pen qui est
pronostiquée comme la future candidate
qui à laquelle sera opposé le candidat
des républicains
comment vous faites chez les
républicains pour vous préparer à ça
qu'est ce que l'équipe juppé sort un
livre bientôt % pour s'attaquer au
programme économique du front national
est-ce que vous commencez à cibler des
arguments a essayé de regarder ce qu'a
fait bruno retailleau un groupe de
républicains au sénat
il ya maintenant trois mois et demi ils
vont sortir un ensemble de documents qui
démonte les propositions économiques et
sociales d'ailleurs du front national
démontrant leur impossibilité démontant
le mensonge qu'il porte c'est sur le
terrain devront prix sur le désir et le
terrain des idées et du combat d'accord
c'est d'ailleurs ce que la majorité
sénatoriale à la fois des républicains
nos amis centristes dans les
propositions qui vont être faites dans
les semaines et les mois qui viennent
vont construire aussi leur part de
projet pour l'alternance et combattre
marine le pen c'est d'abord parler la
vérité pas aller dans des eaux si
peut-être parler la vérité proposer des
voies et moyens pour conduire au
résultat car ce qu'ils vont faire marine
le pen est ce qu'ils adhèrent aux idées
de l'extrême droite pour beaucoup non
mais ils ont le sentiment qu'on a déjà
tout essayé
la gauche et la droite voilà pourquoi
qu'on marisol touraine où monsieur le
guen 10 la gauche et la droite ce n'est
pas pareil
oui c'est pas pareil c'est pas mieux que
ça peut être des gens qui ont voté par
la codi
que ce soit la gauche républicaine le
centre et la droite républicaine et
c'est pas pareil et c'est très bien ça
fait l'idée d'une recomposition
politique ne vous effleure pas à vous
parce qu'on sait que c'est une idée qui
est prêté à manuel valls et même alain
juppé l'évoquent il évoque une
possibilité d'ouvrir aussi la majorité
de centre gauche qu'est-ce que vous quel
est votre avis là dessus rien n'empêche
de s'ouvrir
oui je le crois pas car mon position ne
crois pas l'ouverture à quelques
personnalités
il peut y avoir des projets et un
président de la république qui propose
un projet aux pays qui puisse être
partagée au delà des clivages entre
majorité et opposition
il peut y avoir des sujets de cette
nature général de gaulle l'avait bien
rêver lui pour redresser notre pays en
1958 et pourtant c'était un homme chacun
reconnaît qu'ils avaient des idées très
claires il a cette capacité là françois
fillon justement à pouvoir proposer des
pensions rassembler comme alain juppé
peut rassembler puisque vous citiez ces
deux noms peut être tous les deux ils
ont dit qu'ils étaient clairement
candidat y allons vous n'avez pas cité
depuis le début de cette émission c'est
nicolas sarkozy n'est pas encore
candidat certes mais est ce que pour
vous il un bon président il est encore
dans la course il a bon président de
république je vous le dis et chacun sait
pas liberté ton à son égard et il permet
le débat il permet aussi énorme
en aucun moment entravé la préparation
des mets ce qu'il serait un bon candidat
mais je pense à président de la
république il a les qualités pour l'être
dakar 6 français refusent déjà rejouer
ce match on le savait hélas aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui ils n'ont pas envie du même
match nous verrons au moins de ventes
est-ce qu'il est pas un peu comme
françois hollande nicolas sarkozy l'un
des responsables de la désaffection des
français à l'égard de la politique par
les promesses qui ont été faites et qui
n'ont pas forcément été réalisés nicolas
sarkozy failli a quand même la grande
crise de 2008 à gérer il a plutôt bien
géré et c'est vrai que les français
n'ont pas eu le sentiment des résultats
qui avaient été des engagements de 2007
mais entre temps la crise était passé et
que peut-être sur un certain nombre de
sujets je pense à la réforme notamment
de la tva une tva sociale nous n'avons
pas été au bout
d'un engagement qui a été pris et nous
l'avons fait trop tard mais nicolas
sarkozy le reconnaît lui même est ce que
vous pouvez influencer le programme de
françois fillon sur une thématique par
exemple fiscale est-ce que vous par
exemple vous êtes pour la suppression de
l'impôt sur la fortune sera la chef y
est c'est fait un mauvais 1 poule mais
par exemple je pense que c'est
l'occasion ou jamais de repenser à une
idée qui peut apparaître pour certains
ancien quai la participation ou
l'intéressement
pour redresser pas un pays sans que
chacun en tire des fruits aussi bien les
salariés que les chefs d'entreprise
c'est cette vision que j'ai de la
société donc ça c'est le gaullisme
social qui parle et qui continue à
penser que c'est une idée singulièrement
moderne pour rassembler pays j'ai envie
de rassembler mon pays
d'accord et est ce que vous pensez donc
une dernière fois que twitter vous
racontiez pas exactement bien la
question que françois fillon a vraiment
les chances de remontée de coiffer sur
le poteau je pense que tout est jouable
point jure un quatuor de tête qui ce qui
serait un peu voilà et gloria pas encore
le premier violon si vous voulez
d'accord et nous verrons dans le quatuor
à cordes qui sortira mais l'important
après c'est qu'ils jouent ensemble et
c'est ce à quoi je travaillerai livre
vous aviez encore une question le traité
transatlantique
oui sur le traité transatlantique tout à
fait il ya eu ces derniers temps tout un
tas de déclarations au sein du
gouvernement disant que ça allait être
compliqué de signer ce traité si un
certain nombre de garanties n'étaient
pas respectées sur le lait par exemple
les appellations d'origine contrôlée est
ce que vous vous pensez que c'est une
erreur du gouvernement de ceux de
reculer sur cette signature des choses
d'abord de sela travaille beaucoup sur
ce sujet vous avez déjà eu deux rapports
de la commission pour l'union européenne
et un rapport de la commission des
affaires économiques et que sur ce sujet
j'ai moi même de demander à ce qu'on ait
une analyse en profondeur
ce que je constate c'est que la hausse
il axe franco allemand ne fonctionne pas
si c'est un des grands d'allemagne est
plutôt françois hollande de traité nous
voyons que aujourd'hui un axe
germano-américain ce sujet
absolument et
et qu'il n'ya plus d'actes
franco-allemand et il n'y aura pas
d'avenir à ce traité si on ne
reconstruit pas autour d'un axe franco
allemand
là encore il n'ya pas que la question
des ogm il n'y a pas que la question des
appellations d'origine protégée et l
impact sur la paix sur la viande bovine
il n'y a pas que les sujets d'arbitrage
je pense que nous avons intérêt à
construire un traité qui nous permettent
des relations est ce qu'on peut
continuer à faire que ce soit les états
unis et y compris le congrès américain y
compris les banques américaines le
trésor américain qui nous impose
notamment
regardez ce qui s'est passé pour le
crédit agricole ou la bnp donc nous
avons intérêt à normaliser nos relations
avec les états unis comme nous l'avons
fait avec le canada panneaux des
gouvernements ça ne peut pas être aux
dépens de l'europe et ça ne peut pas
être un accord partiel
et ça se construit les 28 mai notamment
les pays fondateurs et notamment autour
de l'axé franco l'allemagne a l'air plus
favorables aux positions américaines que
ne l'est la et bien il y aura pas de
traité dans ces conditions là je vous le
dis et s'il n'y avait pas entre la
france et l'allemagne
la dimension de la confiance autour de
se prêter n'y aura pas de traité merci
guillaume daudin troisième partie de
près par trois avec michaël szames s de
public sénat
et cette question est ce que le sénat
fait obstacle à la nouvelle réunion du
congrès prévu cette fois pour réformer
le conseil supérieur de la magistrature
le les députés ont voté tout à l'heure
cette réforme que le sénat avait adopté
gérard larcher c'est en 2013 vous y
étiez favorable comme le rappelle en
permanence le ministre de la justice
jean jacques urvoas qui espéraient une
adoption au congrès tous les sénateurs
de droite gérard larcher en tête bruno
retailleau en tête ont voté ce texte et
ce texte a été voté par la droite en
1981 18 je veux montrer que quand on dit
qu'on est favorable à l'indépendance de
la justice et qu'on ne vote pas ce texte
alors et c'est ce que christian jacob
dit aujourd'hui dans le figaro il dit la
phrase je souhaite maintenir les liens
organiques entre la chancellerie et le
parquet disant autrement on veut
caporaliser le parquet c'est à dire qu
on est nostalgique d'une justice aux
ordres
cela veut dire que fait sans jacob veut
choisir
juge qui plaisent au pouvoir politique
voilà l'accusation est assez forte mais
quelle est la vie devant soi mais sur la
justice donc le ministre de la justice
l'a dit cet après-midi après l'adoption
de l'assemblée nationale la voix du
congrès est ouverte
est ce le cas je sais pas si la voie du
congrès est ouverte mais la voix de
jean-jacques urvoas a singulièrement
changé depuis 2013 puisque à l'époque je
rappelle qu'il considérait que le
travail qui avait été fait par une
majorité sénatoriale à ces diverses
à cette époque là était tout à fait
insuffisantes et ne coupez pas le droit
de changer a besoin le dit la chanson
il a changé comme moi moi je n'ai pas
changé je pense que ce qui avait été le
fruit des travaux
je pense notamment de jean jacques hyest
à l'intérieur de la commission des lois
des réflexions aussi de michel mercier
sur l'avis conforme ne coupent
d'ailleurs pas le lien entre la
chancellerie et les nominations seront
présents la chancellerie et le parquet
mais que l'avis conforme sur la pratique
qu'on a depuis un certain nombre de mes
loulous garder ce que nous dit pas s'il
y aura un congrès ou pas mais c'est pas
moi c'est le président de la république
alors est ce que le président la
république de faire un ersatz de
réformes constitutionnelles souvenait le
sujet avait été évoqué est-ce que ça
mérite de convoquer le congrès votre
alignement du monde en je ne suis pas
certain que ça le mérite aujourd'hui
puisque la pratique n'est pas en
distorsion moi si ça vient au congrès je
le voterai à titre personnel
donc les choses sont claires je le veux
treatise personnes vous rejeter tout
procès d'intention du ministre de la
justice
je ne sais pas de procès d'intention je
vous donne mon vote jeudi que le projet
de mise la justice a évolué mais je
considère qu' il appartient au président
de la république de décider ou non si le
convoque le congrès je considère moi
c'est votre avis je considère que la
réunion du congrès n'est pas opportune
aujourd'hui c'est votre avis personnel
comme vous avez donné votre vote les
députés ont voté contre ça veut dire que
là il ya un flou et quand il ya un flou
il ya un autre les députés et les
sénateurs oui pal flou il ya eu un vote
en 2013 par un groupe ump à l'époque
auquel j'appartenais
je ne change pas mon vote jeudi que la
réunion du conseil me paraît pas
opportune d'accord si le président de la
république mais c'est à lui qu'il
appartient de décider s'il réunit où
l'eau ou non le congrès mon vote vous le
connaissez ça c'est clair
qu'est ce que vous répondez à
l'accusation du ministre s'est dit que
la droite alizés oui caporaliser la
justice et yves ldd procureur à tout ça
c'est des mots et que ceci amène un peu
ce que vous à nicolas sarkozy d'annoncer
des mots excessifs
enfin voyons rappelons nous qu elle
était le projet de madame taubira
c'était le corporatisme du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature
puisqu'il s'agissait de donner la
majorité aux magistrats mais la gauche a
beaucoup reproché à nicolas sarkozy
certains avaient la page marleau du
texte par l'eau par eric aullen sarkozy
je vous parle du taq qui a reproché à
michel mercier d'avoir été un garde des
sceaux qui n'est pas respecté
complètement ni le parquet ni la
magistrate magistrature du siège
personne le comportement michel mercier
comme garde des sceaux a été exemplaire
président de la république s'appelait
nicolas sarkozy il ya eu une réunion cet
après-midi à matignon autour du
terrorisme il ya certainement eu des
vocations autour de l'état d'urgence est
ce que vous savez quand aura lieu le
vote sur l'extension de l'état d'urgence
au sénat le 10 mai a priori nous aurons
la prorogation de l'état d'urgence
et personnellement je soutiens cette
prorogation fait de l'euro et est temps
de parole et du tour de france
mais l'état d'urgence ne saurait être un
état permanent et en même temps je me
questionne est-ce qu'on est en état
d'urgence et qu'on laisse le déaut être
pris de force est occupé est-ce qu'on
est en état d'urgence et qu'on laisse
ici ou là je ne parle pas de
manifestations légitimes syndicales
organisées les nuls et du bain de boue
continuer leur violence peut pas y avoir
deux régime de l'état d'urgence
l'état d'urgence est un état
exceptionnel dans lequel il nous faut
garantir aussi la préservation des
droits et vous savez que senna est
extrêmement attentif mais on peut pas
réclamer d'un côté l'état d'urgence et
l'essai de l'autre côté la chienlit ça
veut dire donc que le gouvernement
aujourd'hui n'agit pas aux fonctions par
rapport à l'état d'urgence qui est
actuel aller à 100 mètres du sénat sur
vous verrez si c'est l'état d'urgence
c'est le cirque sépare et à ions
certains comme je répète encore nicolas
sarkozy avait parlé de chienlit à
l'époque vous reprendrez seconde
générale ou du général de gaulle vient
de le reprendre et vous estimez que
vraiment c'est à l'échelle du pays que
cette chienlit cet instinct et noblement
alors les villes du pays et elle je
prends cet exemple oui on est à cent
mètres du sénat et regarder ce qui se
passe
est-ce que c'est appliquer état
d'urgence
donc vous demander des gestes ferme du
marché intérieur que les nuances et sont
égaux face à l'état d'urgence atterrir
ce genre de mots dans la ration est
lâché par ont hâte à dire ces
manifestations comme celle de nuit
debout par exemple il faudrait l'évaluer
à terre ne peut pas continuer à tolérer
derrière chaque mis debout y ait des
violences et vais pas aussi quand même
cette impression qu'on ne sait pas
sortir de cet état d'urgence aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans une situation
exceptionnelle la menace est très élevé
et dans la situation dans laquelle je
suis je sais que c'est vrai que c'est
pas des propos qui seraient les propos
circonstanciel et face à cette menace
élevée
il n'empêche qu'il va falloir un moment
sortir de l'état d'urgence organiser le
pays pour faire face de manière
permanente au risque et en même temps
retrouvé l'état de droit dans sa
plénitude
parce que
l'état d'urgence suspens une partie
quand même des libertés comment fait-on
pour sortir de cet état d'urgence est
une question d'organisation et c'est ce
que conduit actuellement le ministre de
l'intérieur il nous tient informés
il est d'ailleurs ce que fait le premier
ministre c'était jean claude gaudin qui
cet après midi me représenter à cette
réunion
moi même je suis avec beaucoup
d'attention et je recevrai dans 48
heures d'ailleurs et membre éminent
charge du suivi des pourparlers de cette
réunion voulait pas en dire plus
non parce que puiser mois l'importance
et l'efficacité de la sécurité vous
évoquez la sortie de l'état d'urgence
pourtant la menace terroriste avait
toujours la même elle n'a pas changé oui
mais vous ne pouvez pas rester en
permanence en état d'urgence il faut
qu'à un moment le pays s'organisent pour
s'installer face à une donne de risque
qui est différente
d'accord cela ne vous donne pas des
regrets quand on vois l'échec de la
réforme constitutionnelle où vous devez
inscrire l'état d'urgence dans la
constitution
ça aurait pu être une façon aussi de
sortir dignement de cet état d'urgence
et qu'il y ait un cadre non il ya un cas
dans la loi de 55 donc le cadre il
existe fallait-il constitutionnaliser la
réponse le sénat l'a donné clairement le
gouvernement s'est pris les pieds dans
la sphère de la déchéance de nouveaux
crédits c'est ce qu'il vous arrive
aujourd'hui assumer son incapacité
d'avoir pu conduire avec sa majorité
les engagements du président de la
république à versailles chacun se
renvoie la balle est ce qu'il vous en
thierry goor exécutif aujourd'hui envoyé
pardon c'est le président de la
république oui bon bon et vous ont
renvoyé la balle à manuel valls et vous
dit où vous jouez à 2017
y a que ça qui vous intéresse nous pas
du tout j'ai simplement dit que le sénat
avait ligne rouge qui aurait pas d'un
patrick alors quand même pas un scandale
de dire à un homme de gauche qui depuis
les valeurs de gauche qui depuis 1922 se
bat contre la patrie de leur rappeler
quand même et que c'est un combat qui
mérite quelques quelques respect alors
l'accusation effectivement un homme
qu'elle est venu de la gauche on vous
avait accusé de jouer en fête 2010 est
l'alternance et vous personnellement
c'est le sénateur ps luc carvounas qui
vous accuse de manquer d'impartialité
gérard larcher lors des questions
d'actualité on l'écouté vous allez
pouvoir lui répondre d'ailleurs gérard
larcher hier était extrêmement virulent
a coupé le micro de tout le monde donc
c'est pas non plus ma conception de
l'animation de l'hémicycle gérard
larcher coup plus vite le micro quand il
s'agit d'un orateurs de gauche que de
droite et il est beaucoup plus cool sur
le timing et le chrono quand il s'agit
d'un orateurs de droite que de gauche
il suffit de regarder ce qui se passe
votre réponse totalement faux j'ai fait
un petit statistiques que j'ai rapporté
ya trois semaines en conférence des
présidents
la différence entre socialistes et
républicains ces 52 centièmes de seconde
pendant trois mois vous rendez compte si
carvounas et sensible c'est un sprinteur
et même les communistes ont dépassé de 8
secondes
16 les écologistes de 7 secondes pour
vous rendez compte
en messieurs carvounas il faut qu'il
reprenne son chronomètre d'hier a lâché
pour rester un petit peu sur ces
questions d'actualité dabo sur les
réformes qui ont été amenés au sénat il
ya eu ce droit de réplique qui est
arrivé est ce que ça a changé
fondamentalement la donne des questions
d'actualité au sénat
je pense qu'il ya deux choses c'est que
chaque semaine nous nous retrouvons pour
des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement et que donc il commence
quelque part à y avoir un rendez vous
avec une partie du pays autour des
questions d'actualité au sénat que ce
soit le mardi
et la semaine suivante le jeudi c'est
aussi je crois le sentiment que le sénat
ait où travaille et on le voit dans
l'application tout simplement des règles
de fonctionnement que sont maintenant
rentrer dans tous les esprits avec une
valorisation du travail du du sénat je
sens dans le pays mais et c'est partager
et d'ailleurs nous voyons bien ce
d'ailleurs ça bénéficie à public sénat
et nous avons des audiences chi chi chi
mods avons plus de 320 mail abonnée à
twitter
notre cité est incroyablement fréquenté
tout ceci nous amène dans une meilleure
rencontre avec le pays et je dois dire
que les sénateurs majorité comme
opposition en sept rencontres plus forte
me semble-t-il avec le pays c'est en
tous les cas ce que je ressens que je
ressent très fortement y compris par
rapport à la masse des changes que je
peux avoir avec les nos compatriotes
monsieur le président il ya deux cas de
déclaration mensongère devant des
commissions du sénat
ce sont deux cas bien distincts on va
bien faire la distinction celui de
michel aubier keita célèbre pneumologue
au sujet de l'impact du désert sur la
santé celui de frédéric oudéa ancien
président du cas à l'époque de la
société générale pour une affaire de
paradis fiscaux le sénat at il été
bafouée à tous les cas que la procédure
soit engagée
c'est légitime c'est légitime parce que
venir devant une commission d'enquêté et
s'exprimer sous serment c'est quelque
chose de le sérieux c'est même quelque
chose de symbolique et que donc quand on
est vraiment l ancien je qualifie pas la
faute nous verrons une fois la procédure
la procédure se déroule en bureau du
sénat va donc examiner à la suite d'une
nouvelle audition qu'a fait l'ancien
président monsieur husson l'ancien
rapporteur la magie du professeur aubier
claude bérit-debat rapportera devant le
bureau
qu'est ce qu'il m'avait xavier peu
risqué mais surtout parce qu'il peut
risquer c'est plus simplement que bureau
décide ou non de transmettre au
procureur de la république alors procuré
concernant le président de la société
génère alors on est sur un sujet assez
comparable qui a été ratée je le
rappelle est réellement un par les
révélations de panama peppers sur les
paradis fiscaux et tous les regards mais
la commission des finances gilles et
rappeler cet après midi en plein après
midi la commission des finances est dans
son rôle quand elle procède à un
contrôle qu'elle va procéder à un
contrôle
en même temps l'ancien président de la
commission denquête messieurs dominati a
souhaité entendre monsieur oudéa et
ensuite ils ont la capacité de saisir le
bureau qui examinera suivant la même
procédure
au mois de mai et quelles sont les
conséquences pour monsieur oudéa lors le
communiste alain bocquet lui demande la
saisie du bureau immédiatement dès la
saisie avec des sanctions peut être
allez on va l'écouter à l'invoquer
répondu j'espère que vous entendrez la
première j'ai appris voilà vous jeu
monsieur larcher le président du sénat
que monsieur oudéa serait auditionné le
11 mai prochain ce qui est une bonne
chose maintenant créons les conditions
pour que cette audition débouche sur la
vérité parce que moi j'ai simplement mis
en regard les déclarations de monsieur
des apps faites sous serment le 17 avril
2012 et les révélations faites par l'epa
damas papers et à hiatus entre les deux
à l'évidence erratique sous serment
parce que c'est important et ça qu'il a
menti sous serment il aurait menti sous
serment
sera-t-il alors il sera pas sous serment
arni saison qui vient bien de l'émission
d' enquête mais la présidente de la
commission et je ne doute pas monsieur
dominati et monsieur évoqué mme feront
part de leurs sentiments et je me
soumettrai ensuite pour instruction au
bureau dans cette une procédure est
d'ailleurs monsieur bloqué vient de
reconnaître qu'il fallait pas faire dans
immédiats les données les délais
nécessaires savez on est sur des
matières qui nécessite à la fois la
vérité la solidité et on n'est pas sous
la pulsion
par contre il est de mon devoir de faire
que devant une commission d enquête du
sénat
quand on parle sous serment
on dise la vérité et rien que la vérité
quand vous l'avez vécu tout cela à titre
peut-être personnel vous qui habitez par
le sénat mais je pense que c'est le
sénat qui joue parfaitement son rôle
vous voyez on ne considère pas que les
affaires passe comme ça que ce soit sur
la sphère de la santé publique ou la
faire de l'éthique financière
le sénat est dans son rôle et dans sa
fonction de contrôle
et voilà je dis toujours que le sénat a
une responsabilité particulière dans le
contrôle et vous voyez que le contrôle
nous l'appliquer alors qu'avez vous à
dire aux accusations d'une association
qui s'appelle démocratie directe qui
accuse députés et sénateurs et même vous
même d'avoir touché ce qu'on pourrait
appeler dès des suppléments de
rémunération d'indemnités
supplémentaires
d'abord je dis attention hein attention
tout ça relève ce devrait être ma
conclusion d'un âne antiparlementarisme
qu'on cultive et je dis aussi attention
journalistes je le dis avec respect mais
de répondre ce genre de choses sans
avoir vérifié au préalable d'ailleurs je
n'ai reçu que deux jours après la lettre
de monsieur lebreton méthode résidence
est associé et ensuite j'ai pu lui
répondre une base légale 1947 une base
légale parce que quand générale de la
sécurité code de la sécurité sociale
cg contrôle de la cour des comptes et
comparaison avec d'autres parlements je
pense à l'allemagne le royaume uni y
aura des sens des choses comparé à j'ai
fait la réponse à monsieur lebreton
j'ai vu qu'ils sont pressés - d'être sur
les ondes pour expliquer la réponse que
je lui avais fait monsieur bartolone
je crois qu'il faut simplement faire
attention attention à
l'anti-parlementarisme dans ces temps de
crise c'est facile mais c'est dangereux
pour la télé quand les candidats de
droite tous demandent moins de
parlementer
reste aux participants par benoît on
parle de réformes mais aussi je ne dis
pas que la procédure parlementaire ne
doivent pas être réformé
j'ai moi-même dans la réforme du sénat
est proposé et ça fait partie d'ailleurs
des propositions que je viens d'envoyer
au président de groupe à la suite du
travail de monsieur karoutchi d'al-arich
a est ce qu'on me donne pas un temps de
commissions et un temps de séance un peu
différent pour aller plus vers la péta
bien merci merci merci monsieur le
président du sénat merci à tous bon soir
à trèves et à la semaine prochaine